2026년 4월 23일 목요일 미국 증시 의학입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 하락 마감했습니다.
이란 전쟁이 조기에 종식될 것이라는 기대감이 후퇴한 가운데
주요 기업들의 실적 발표를 계기로 AI가 소프트웨어 산업을 위협할 수 있다는 우려가 다시 부각되면서
시향은 변동성 장세 속에 하락했습니다.
장 초반 증시는 이란의 호르무제어 통제력 강화 소식에도 보악권에 머물렀습니다.
하지만 장중 이란 의회의장이 협상단에서 사임했다는 소식이 전해지며 증시는 이내 약세로 돌아섰습니다.
이어 이란의 공습 보도로 유가가 급등하면서 지수 낙폭은 더욱 커졌습니다.
이란 반간용 파르스 통신은 전국 여러 지역에서 소형 드론에 대응하기 위해 반공망을 가동했다고 보도했습니다.
이에 따라 SN표부 지수는 장중 한때 1.3%까지 급락했으나 장 후반 들어 낙폭을 일부 만회했습니다.
트럼프 대통령은 이란이 합의를 원하고 있으며 미국 역시 이란과의 대화를 이어가고 있다고 밝혔습니다.
다만 합의가 불발될 경우 군사적 수단을 동원해 이란의 남은 표적들을 타격함으로써 상황을 완전히 종결짓겠다고 경고했습니다.
아울러 미국 국민들에게는 당분간 휘발유 가격 인상을 감수해야 할 것이라고 당부했습니다.
투자들은 주요 기업들의 실적 배폐에도 집중했습니다.
IBM과 서비스나우의 실적이 AI발 산업 재편의 우려를
불시시키지 못하면서 소프트웨어 관련 주가 큰 타격을 입었습니다.
테슬라는 시장의 예상치를 웃도는 후 실적을 발표했음에도 향후 지출 확대 계획이 부각되며 주가가 하락했습니다.
반면 텍세스 인스트루먼트는 견주한 실적 전망을 제시하며 주가가 급등했습니다.
정규장 종료 후 인텔은 긍정적인 실적 전망을 발표하며 시간의 거래에서 급등했습니다.
지자체 리스크가 지속되고 있음에도 불구하고 견주한 기업 실적과 탄탄한 경제 지표 덕분에
SN표부 지수는 2.3%로 늘었습니다.
2023년 이후 월간 기준 최고의 수익률을 기록할 전망입니다.
블룸버그에 따르면 현재까지 실적을 발표한 S&P500 편익기업 중 약 80%가
1분기 시장 전망치를 상회하는 후 실적을 기록했습니다.
forex.com의 파하드 라자크 자단은 양국 간 외고 향방에 상당한 불확실성이 존재한다.
더욱 불안한 요소는 호르메이접을 둘러싼 상황이 계속해서 불투명하다는 점입니다.
웰스파구의 3일을 삼아 나는 핵심 문제는 여전히 호르무지에어입니다.
미국과 이란 양측이 모두 강경한 입장을 고수하고 있는 상황에서
합의에 도달하기는 쉽지 않아 보인다. 라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 4월 24일 금요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제지표는 23시 미국 4월 미시간대 기대인플레이션
23시 미국 4월 미시간대 소비자 심리지수
02시 미국 베이커 유즈 총 시축 이수가 예정되어 있습니다.
잉크 organised.com
99NN along with you
ordo